they're some of the only friends
Vladimir Putin has left leaders are
former Soviet States median Saint
Petersburg on the 31st anniversary of
the fall of the Soviet Union
but even friendly countries seem to be
concerned with Putin's approach to
Ukraine and the message is getting
through
we have to admit unfortunately that
disagreements are emerging also between
members about how to maintain security
and stability within the region
when Ally Putin can count on Alexander
lukashenko the Bella Russian president
has recently approved a flurry of
military activity leading Western
countries to believe they could join the
war in Ukraine soon
in response ukrainians have stepped up
training practicing to stop a potential
attack at the Belarus Ukraine border
similar to an unsuccessful Russian
attempt in the early days of the war and
while Ukrainian soldiers keep preparing
on the battlefield the idea of the peace
formula is twofold the odds of a
negotiated end of the war are increasing
the Ukrainian foreign minister outlining
a new plan for a peace Summit in
February the United Nations could be the
best venue for holding this uh this
Summit because this is not about making
a favor to a certain country this is
really about bringing everyone on board
the one catch Dimitri culeba says Russia
would first need to face prosecution for
war crimes at an international court
before they could be invited Ukraine is
also calling on the U.N to have Russia
removed as a permanent member of the
security Council arguing the idea was
already being discussed in diplomatic
circles it's only a matter of time when
the actions of the Russian Federation
will destroy the entire U.N system the
Ukrainian foreign Ministry says
Ukraine's hoping the United Nations
Secretary General will help moderate the
talks but the there's no word from the
UNF they're willing to fulfill that role
but more importantly nithu there's no
word from Russia on if they're willing
to accept the Ukrainian invitation
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mackenzie